あ、こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
カードショップによく行くんですけど
そのカードショップにガチャガチャが沢山あるんですよ
そのガチャガチャですごい
面白そうなや
つが売ってたので買ってみました
ボノロン
きた、こちら
マジカル・マジック
ネーミングセンスを疑う
なにやら水の中にいるときだけ固って
そうじゃない時はただの砂らしいです
怪しいと思った時にはすでに時遅かった
気づいたら9回、回してました
全種類欲しかったから仕方ないこればかりは
こういうのはなんとなく全種類集めたくなるタイプの人間なので
しゃー
すげー、オシャレ
こういう置き方もできるんだ
あ、あぁやろう
はいというわけで、こちらの6色になります
ひとまず水を持っていきましょう
もう、今回思う存分遊ぶために
最高のフィールドを準備したからな
これだけデカかったら遊び放題っしょ
もう入れますね
これで固まるんでしょ、だって
！？
うっおｌとっえうぃｇｒはっ
うおおすごいすごい
キモい。
うわーすごい、沈むと、蛇みたいになっちゃった
え、これすごい、ちょっと待って、全色出してみましょう
うおおーうおおーすごい
え、これすごいな、待って
普通に楽しいんだけど
すごいな
うわ、待って、すごいすごいすごい
うええーキモイよー
うわわちょあじもｒうぃ
ちょ、奥の　ちょ、ちょ、浮く　お前ら、ちょ
ちょおまちょちょおまちょ
はいというわけでこんな感じでござい、ちょ浮くなちょい
上の浮遊物がすごい
君達は入らないのかい？
でも、なんかもうこんな感じで下は本当に
グロさは伝わると思います
こんな感じです
これ混ぜたらカラフルになるのかな？
混ぜてみよう
失礼しまーす
一応全部固まります
中だと粘土みたいになりますね
これ地上に出すとさ
ワシの予想なんだけど
うわぁ、砂になっちゃった
うわぁ、本当に砂じゃん
wwちょっと待てぇ
お前ら落ちないのか？
本当、でも砂になるからすごいんすよね
はぁ！！
（私は思ってしまった）
（この砂は）
（動画的に応用力がない）
すごく楽しいなーこれはもうワクワクワクワクだよ
HA HA HA HA
（やべぇよ、これどうすんだよ）
（水の中だと粘土になる）
（上に出せば砂になる）
（それだけやないかーい）
( ^)o(^ )
ん！！
これ思ったんですけど
地上に出すと水をはじいて砂になるんすよ
これ、もしはじけない水だったら、果たしてこの粘土ちゃんはどうなるのでしょうか
あ、待って、目に入った
待って待ってガチだガチだちょちょ待って待って
すいません、失明するところでした
水から離すと砂になるということは
今、砂になってますよね、水を乗せても
こう弾くんですよ水を
もし、この水を弾く
もし、この水に、え？
もう分からなくなってきちゃった
あなたは誰ぇ？
水を弾くということは
弾かない水だったｒ
ひょっとしたら、この子たちは
地上でもひょっとして、こいつたちは粘土として使えるかもしれない
どうしても地上に出た瞬間、砂になっちゃう可哀想な子達を
なんとかして
粘土にするために
地上に出たこの砂達に
ローションをぶちかけて
地上でもなんとか両生類にしてあげたいんですよ
僕は、両生類にしてあげたい
地の国と
水の国、両方の国でちゃんと活躍できるように
僕がねローションでこの子達を地上でも粘土にできるようにしてみたいと思います
ひとまず全員上がれー
砂の姿でなるべくこっちに移してあげよう
結構いったでしょう
もう、水を弾いてるわけですよ、こういう風に
よーしお前達、俺が救ってやるからなー
おえーーぷわわおえーー！
粉だった
この子たちはちゃんと
陸でもちゃんとした粘土になれるのでしょうか
ぺぺローションかけていきましょう
これで戻ったらホントに
あ、いいんじゃない？でも
ファーストコンタクト悪くないよ
なんかなんか、良い感じです、今のところは
触ってみましょう
な、なにこれ
何これ、待って
スライムになっちゃった
すごい、ローションがスライムになる
ローション、だってこんなに手に持てないし
スライムっすね
結構これ大発見ですよ
ローション+魔法の砂でスライムができることが今回わかりました
すごいこれはMAJIDE
それにカラフルだしね
というわけで皆さんもし、魔法の砂持っていたら
ローションと混ぜてスライム作ってみてはいかがでしょうか
じゃあな！
（これは何に使うんだろう）
普通にスライムと粘土を買うことを強くおすすめします。
1919810
ファッ！？
※動画の説明欄にURLがあります
ででででん